[Musique]
je vais revenir sur le projet qui est
pour moi le plus excitant électrifié le
Québec
on va retrouver nos deux panélistes ce
soir Hugo la vallée et Michel c.og
bonsoir à vous deux bonsoir bonsoir
alors ce qu'on vient d'entendre c'est
monsieur Legault à la sortie de son
caucus professionnel ça sonnait à Laval
décliner ici ces priorités pour la
nouvelle session mais clairement c'est
le dossier de l'énergie qui l'excite le
plus manifestement c'est comme ça qu'il
le présentait des carboner le Québec ce
sera sa ligne directive en fait Michel
ce sera même le fondement de sa vision
économique pour le Québec pour le
prochain mandat
oui ce qu'il faut comprendre aussi c'est
que Monsieur Lebeau était critique au
cours des dernières semaines pour son
empressement à bâtir de nouveaux
barrages maintenant les barrages sont
rendus vert puis qui vont servir à des
carboner le Québec alors il y a comme
une
verdissement des barrages qui s'est
exécuté au cours des derniers jours là
pour montrer que c'est pas vrai que
c'était juste du développement
industriel traditionnel amener une
éliminerie lorsqu'ils
les coûts d'énergie après ça peut-être
avant d'autres américains c'est pour des
carboner le Québec alors il
présente ça mais ça de l'avant mais on
continue de voir que ce qu'il veut avoir
dans sa poche c'est des projets de
barrage entre autres pour négocier avec
Terre-Neuve et aussi bien sûr pour faire
de la lumière et puis toutes les belles
choses dont tu parles depuis quelques
jours on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
justement c'est négociations qui
s'enviennent avec Terre-Neuve parce que
il y a fait allusion aussi mais quand
vous êtes il essaie de d'une certaine
façon de bien emballer son message il le
fait aussi avec la critique qu'on
entendue dans le cadre du départ de
sophie Brochu de la tête d'Hydro-Québec
quand elle parlait du Dollarama du
Québec avec des tarifs préférentiels
pour les grosses industries Hugo on sent
aussi ici que le gouvernement veut
corriger le tir et il présente une autre
façon aujourd'hui on a senti que
monsieur Legault choisissait bien ses
mots et le bien mis en évidence le mot
éolienne le mot aussi économie d'énergie
il veut montrer que c'est pas juste une
question de barrage et effectivement il
y a aussi ce nouveau concept de
modulation des tarifs d'électricité qui
l'a mis de l'avant un peu plus fortement
parce que jusqu'ici ce qu'on nous disait
c'est qu'on va avoir plus d'énergie on
va pouvoir attirer des entreprises
vertes mais là on veut pousser le
concept un peu plus loin en disant non
seulement on va attirer de nouvelles
entreprises mais même pour celles qui
sont déjà là il faut revoir l'ensemble
de la grille tarifaire puis tenir compte
non seulement des retombées économiques
que les projets génèrent puis que les
entreprises génèrent mais aussi tenir
compte donc du plan de réduction de gaz
à effet de serre de ces entreprises là
de leur empreinte carbone
dans une logique de zéro émission en
2050 pas inintéressant comme idée ben
évidemment ça va être devoir jusqu'où
monsieur Lego va être prêt à pousser ça
là quand il va y avoir cette
consultation un peu plus tard cette
année est-ce qu'on va vraiment être prêt
à dire à certaines entreprises plus
polluantes peut-être dans certaines
régions désolé on va vous imposer des
tarifs beaucoup plus importants parce
que vous respectez pas le plan vous
imaginez déjà qu'il reste y avoir de la
contestation de la grogne dans des
régions où justement ces entreprises là
sont importantes donc ça va être dans le
détail qu'on va vraiment savoir mais en
tout cas au moins dans le discours on
sent que Monsieur le goût ainsi de se
montrer un peu ouvert puis de tendre un
peu la main d'une certaine façon à ceux
qui lui reprochait de trop mettre
l'accent sur les bars et on s'entend
justement parce qu'il y avait plusieurs
sujets qui ont été déclinés mais il est
resté longtemps sur le thème de
l'énergie on avait encore l'impression
qu'il répondait aux critiques de toutes
sortes qu'on a pu entendre nos analyses
de toutes sortes aussi voici un petit
extrait
un gros défi
juste pour décarboner le Québec va
falloir augmenter la capacité
d'Hydro-Québec de
50%. donc rien doit être exclu
efficacité énergétique plus des reliés
possiblement des barrages
maintenant de la part de monsieur
Legault quand il utilise le mot barrage
il a quand même pris le temps de parler
d'efficacité énergétique plus
d'éoliennes donc d'y aller avec une
graduation
et moi je pense que c'est la première
fois cette année un truc que j'entends
parler de fierté énergétique et c'est un
peu ce que beaucoup de gens dont moi
nous avons reproché dans nos chroniques
un moment donné excusez moi mais madame
stratégique d'Hydro-Québec disait
d'abord par là que ça allait passer
alors Monsieur Lego il est en pris un
peu de temps avant de rejoindre ce
train-là mais là il dit les bonnes
choses alors
on commence dans le bon ordre et on va
voir comment ça va se traduire dans la
réalité évidemment mais c'est clair que
son discours a changé son discours a été
Verdi si je peux vous dire de m'exprimer
comme ça au cours des derniers cours des
derniers jours parce que les mots clés
c'est vraiment ça décarbonate ça va te
faire avec lui avec du développement
économique avec des emplois finalement
avec de meilleurs finances pour le
Québec parce qu'il faut que ça nous
rapporte aussi
c'est l'esprit d'un leg et quand il
parle des barrages il est rajouté une
nouvelle donnée
jouer le jeu quel est l'intérêt de
Terre-Neuve est-ce que c'est de d'avoir
justement négociation rapide ou plutôt
de se laisser désirer d'attendre de voir
ce qui peut se présenter comme
opportunité comme occasion à saisir
aussi pour Terre-Neuve qui pourrait
peut-être trouver d'autres usages à
cette énergie là mais en même temps
peut-être si monsieur Legault par
exemple vous voulez faire un geste à
l'égard de Terre-Neuve par exemple
est-ce qu'on pourrait mettre fin plutôt
prévu au contrat si en échange bon on
pouvait développer par exemple l'autre
projet là au Labrador Island ça pourrait
peut-être faire partie des discussions
donc on sent que Monsieur le goût veut
ouvrir le jeu dans la main internet ceci
dit évidemment il y aura beaucoup
beaucoup de méfiance de la part des
Terre-Neuviens peu importe ce que le
Québec aura proposé pour les raisons
historiques qu'on connaît en disant que
Cécile début d'un long processus et là
on sait même pas encore tout à fait le
si le premier ministre ne vient et
vraiment ouvert à cette discussion là à
ce moment parce que Michel probablement
49 on se dit on veut pas se faire avoir
deux fois par le Québec
c'est ainsi et à coût de revient 10 fois
plus bas que le deuxième du
kilowattheure qui est ce qui est ce que
ça coûte de produire d'énergie dans les
barrages au Québec puis des fois on va
se l'électricité là New York l'été quand
eux sont en période de points à 6 ou 800
les revendications Terre-Neuve et et
l'amertume de Terre-Neuve par rapport à
tout ce qui s'est passé au Québec dans
le cas de churching Ford est énorme et
c'est magnifique parce qu'il est arrivé
non pas on verra si ça marche mais à
mascotte forte qui est une autre
centrale qu'on a bâti au Labrador qui a
coûté deux fois et demi le prix prévu
qui était une espèce de grand scandale
et qui était présenté comme la façon
dont terreur valait s'affranchir du
Québec alors il y a du mécontentement du
mauvais sentiment envers le Québec à
terneuve et ça va être pour même si le
nouveau Premier ministre est pas
vraiment impliqué dans dans
le passé récent dans les questions
d'énergie internet ça va être difficile
de faire avant ça au terme de bien et
puis Hugo monsieur monsieur Legault il
avait un petit peu ouvert son jeu là
quand ils ont présenté l'importance de
négociation avec ternaire et Labrador il
dit moi j'arrive pas là avec rien
j'arrive là avec comment dire un outil
négociation c'est que si on n'arrive pas
à s'entendre je me retourne vers mes
propres projets de barrage et là il
avait lancé moi j'en ai plusieurs des
projets de barrage j'en ai jusqu'à 5
aujourd'hui lorsqu'il a présenté son
point de presse il y a des journalistes
qui lui ont demandé pouvez-vous me
donner plus de détails c'est où ça c'est
cinq projets en fait vous voyez ça sur
quelle rivière au Québec là tout à coup
il dévoile plus son jeu du tout non et
c'est certain que Monsieur Lego voudra
pas donner de nom de quelques rivières
que ce soit pour l'instant parce
qu'évidemment imaginez le du moment
qu'il le ferait c'est certain qu'on
entendrait des groupes d'opposants dans
certaines régions déjà on mobiliserait
la contre l'idée d'un barrage on sait
que c'est moins populaire dans les
barrages qu'à une certaine époque
particulièrement pour les communautés
qui habitent à proximité la réalité
c'est que monsieur Legault effectivement
essaie de si on veut de montrer ses
muscles de montrer qu'ils se laissera
pas intimider par terre neuve qui a un
plan B puis que c'est pas grave s'ils
veulent pas signer on va trouver une
autre façon de parvenir à nos fins la
réalité des choses c'est que ce serait
quand même beaucoup plus avantageux pour
le Québec même si on devait payer
l'énergie plus cher contre la paix en ce
moment de signer à nouveau avec Internet
pas de négociation nécessairement avec
des communautés de Première nation en
fait moins de problèmes à gérer et même
dans le cas de Galles eyelin le projet
est en partie déjà autorisé parce qu'il
était lié au projet de Mass dont Michel
parlait tout à l'heure alors ce serait
même peut-être encore plus avantageux de
développer ce projet-là au Labrador
qu'un projet en territoire québécois
donc monsieur Legault visiblement oui
essaie de dire qu'on se laissera pas
impressionner mais il y a quand même
probablement intérêt quand même comme je
le disais tantôt à faire un geste envers
toi ça pourrait être avant qu'on passe à
un autre sujet Michel une autre réaction
là-dessus ou pas
il faut pas oublier que géographiquement
pendant des années des années le seul
qui a possible pour l'énergie produite
produite au laboratoire c'est le Québec
il y en avait pas d'autres là maintenant
ils ont un câble sous-marin qui amène
tout ça jusqu'à nouvel Écosse et là
c'est relié à la grille dans laquelle
sauf que c'est pas une capacité absolue
c'est quand même des technologies
difficile ce n'est qu'un sous-marins qui
transporte d'électricité donc un moment
donné c'est peut-être dans l'intérêt de
Turner de dire ok continuez d'acheter
l'électricité à churchilloise mais voici
le prix par exemple alors on verra
comment qu'elle tournure vont prendre
ces négociations quand elles vont
commencer on est toujours dans l'esprit
du leg la vision de monsieur Legault le
rôle qu'il veut jouer non seulement
pendant son mandat mais dans l'histoire
du Québec là c'est sur la langue
française on l'écoute
le gouvernement de la CAQ soit le
gouvernement dans l'histoire du Québec
qui aura arrêté déclin du français puis
on aura permis de partir dans l'autre
direction c'est à dire de voir une
augmentation du pourcentage de
francophones au Québec
bon alors ce matin et ça précédait le
point de presse de monsieur Legault on
avait le ministre Robert je accompagné
de plusieurs ministres qui présentait un
outil finalement une volonté de faire
des consultations et d'arriver avec un
plan d'action l'automne prochain pour
pour finalement protéger le français une
fois pour toute alors est-ce que est-ce
que c'est à ça qu'il pense monsieur
legault-y avec nous avec la carte là il
y a un avant puis après sur la
sauvegarde de langue française
uniquement à ceux qui pensent ça ira pas
très très loin et effectivement parce
que là pour l'instant nous parle d'un
comité ministériel qui va faire un état
des lieux qui va s'entourer d'experts
qui va consulter la population quelque
chose d'un peu étrangeant parce que
justement à part l'énergie le lot de
grande priorité du discours d'ouverture
de monsieur Legault c'était la
protection du français mettre fin au
déclin on nous dit que urgence d'agir là
qu'il faut justement prendre des mesures
dès maintenant
en même temps on n'a pas l'impression
que le gouvernement a beaucoup lui-même
réfléchi à concrètement ce qu'il faut
faire pour atteindre cet objectif-là
probablement parce que le gouvernement
lui-même pendant des mois nous a dit
avec le projet de loi 96 la question est
à peu près réglée ou en tout cas on va
avoir fait le gros bout du chemin et on
se retrouve dans une situation où on
nous dit bah non faut vraiment faire
plus il faut agir très vite mais c'est
pas clair ce qu'on veut faire alors
c'est pas une intéressant que le comité
se penche là dessus qu'on fasse un état
des lieux c'est vrai que depuis les
États généraux sur la langue française
au début des années 2000 on n'a pas fait
d'exercice de consultation de cet
ampleur là les ministres impliqués
éducation enseignement supérieur culture
immigration c'est pas une intéressant
non plus mais disons que ça va ça va
prendre plus que ça parce que pour
l'instant on reste quand même sur notre
pays et on note l'absence dans ce groupe
de 6 ministres qui vont travailler
là-dessus l'absence du ministre sinon
j'en ai barré de celui qui est derrière
la loi 96 la modernisation de la loi 101
Michel mais on se pose la question aussi
des consultations il y en a eu pour la
loi 96 alors finalement que ça servir
quelque chose cette loi là
de ce qui était annoncé aujourd'hui par
le gouvernement parce qu'on dit ah si
vous venez de de d'allumer sur le fait
qu'elle loi 96 marche pas le mouvement
Québec français par exemple envoyer des
communicants en disant c'est la preuve
que la loi 96 marche pas il recommence
avec un nouveau comité alors
[Musique]
les gens qui sont très préoccupés par le
débat linguistique ne voit pas ça comme
un bon début déjà c'est c'est que une
autre part Hugo le dit c'était supposé
être une grande loi la loi 96 on avait
même mis une clause dérogatoire de
l'avant de façon
préventive
non on recommence on recommence avec un
comité puis monsieur le Président
il y a une confusion dans le message et
le dernier recensement qui a été dévoilé
l'été dernier en faisant qu'on s'est
rendu compte que le nombre de personnes
qui parlent français à la maison a
baissé on est devenu très inquiète on
s'est il faut il faut agir Michel
mais la langue maternelle est-ce que
c'est le bon critère pour vous avez si
des gens aimaient
de parler espagnol à la maison ça veut
pas dire qu'il parle pas français ça
alors il y a
tout le monde dans ce débats y compris
dans cette affaire là alors il faudrait
il faudrait qu'on s'entende sur une base
mais parce que la francisation d'un
immigrants ne signifie pas qui va
arrêter de parler sa langue première ça
c'est c'est
alors ce sont les deux axes que nous a
donné le gouvernement le goût monsieur
Legault avant la reprise de la session
alors on retourne au travail tout le
monde avec cette nouvelle session qui
commence à se faire une prochaine Hugo
Michel merci beaucoup profitez bien
votre fin de semaine bonne fin de
semaine au revoir